I don't really see it as a scene in the
film I see it as a sequence because it's
so iconic we thought wouldn't it be
really fun to take the audience and jump
into the crater without an idiot we
actually put our a camera operator in a
stunt wire rig he ran headfirst into the
crater and that's how we achieved that
shot very logistically challenging set
but very pleasing to working
please
Alejandro wanted to use this wide angle
lenses I felt that he was his way of
writing and telling the story visually
the whole family photography is
anomorphic lenses that photograph the
landscape of Mexico in an incredible way
and the actors are very present we are
around him and we see his world mapped
around him
we were going to replicate this concert
exactly we've scoured Australia for
period light fixtures for the TV studio
and the cameras that were in the TV
studio as well we put one of our film
cameras into the housing of the TV
camera so being exactly the right
position and we would rehearse with him
on stage so that by the time we shot it
we're all in harmony
[Music]
if you're here then you already know who
she is
taunt immediately said well actually we
have to shoot this in one and I
absolutely jumped at that so the idea
then being that Lydia would basically
Drive the editorial and she would move
us through those different shots and I
think that's why double perception as
possible because for some people it
never feels like a One-Shot trying to
figure things out keep the audience at a
level of heightened awareness you want
to dance the mask you must service the
compo
started off just discussing the overall
conception of how we were going to move
the camera relative to the actors and we
would sort of dream about what we wanted
to do to visualize the story
[Applause]
[Music]
comes down to it's an instinct you kind
of feel a shot
it just feels right doesn't it
foreign